hallo mein Name ist L meine lieben
Freunde einige unter euch wissen ja dass
ich seit zwei Jahren ein Tattoo auf
meinem rechten Oberschenkel habe das ich
allerdings nicht mehr so cool finde und
mir gedacht habe ey ich möchte das
weglazern lassen das passt super weil
ich bin laserlaca
übrigens ist dieses Video hier nicht
bezahlt mehr Leute als jemals zuvor
haben aktuell Tattoos und deswegen habe
ich auch dementsprechend viele
Nachrichten erreicht wie das war mit den
Schmerzen wie so eine laserbahnung
abläuft deswegen dachte ich mir ich
reagiere jetzt einfach mal gemeinsam mit
euch drauf herzlich willkommen auf
unserem Youtube-Kanal heute haben wir
einen besonderen Gast bei uns der sich
ein Tattoo bei uns entfernen lässt viele
werden ihn kennen es ist laserler
herzlich willkommen hi
hi von der Seite so reinpa mit HE das
sind zwar bei dir dünne Linien am
Oberschenkel aber viele haben jetzt so
die Vorstellung so eine Linie oder
müsste schneller weggehen als irgendwie
eine Fläche wir werden aber hier nur an
der oberen Schicht erstmal die Farbe
zertrümmern können und müssen deswegen
auch immer die A8 Wochen dazwischen
warten ja das äh ist schon mal Fakt
Nummer 1 Tattoo weglasern geht nicht so
schnell wie Tattoo stechen lassen wo du
halt hingehst dann machst du irgendwie
keine Ahung Schriftzug dauert 5 Minuten
bis durch Lasern ist ein Ablauf das
dauert auch irgendwie 5 Minuten sowas
Weg zu lasern aber da muss man 8 Wochen
warten D muss man es wieder machen
wieder 8 Wochen warten wieder machen
also ich glaube wir haben das so aus dem
Kopf raus bei dir glaube ich auf Zeh
Sitzung geschät mit unserem Kalkulator
weiß nicht mehr
genau das Bild sagt alles sein Blick und
dann ich keine Ahnung wenn wir da nicht
lang genug wachten also wir machen extra
8 Wochen dann kommen wir nicht so gut
auf die tiefere Schicht die dann
zertrümmert werden soll er gibt ja er
gibt also ich meine gibt ja auch aber
genauso war ich auch Physikunterricht
die ganze Zeit molekularteilchen P mal 8
ja er gibt den er gibt SN also es geht
ja darum dass wir möglichst wenig
Sitzung machen und ich glaube du bist
auch ziemlich entspannt was die
Schmerzen angeht ne ja also ich meine B
jetzt meine erste Sitzung ne ich weiß
nicht wie entspannt ich da sein werde
aber ja das also zu dem Zeitpunkt konnte
ich es halt noch nicht beurteilen ne
natürlich denkt man sich bisschen so
okay Schmerzen irgendwie deutlich
krasser als bei Tattoo stechen aber ihr
seht ja gleich mal wie ich das
ausgehalten habe hier ne warum spann ich
mein Bizeps an kannst ruhig
Pause sagen und Stopp wenn das zu viel
ich Zeh
durch ich bin mit so Selbstvertrauen
reingegangen noch nie das
gemacht ich schaff das schon theoretisch
kannst dazu kommen dass die Pigmente
auch aus der Haut rausgeschossen werden
kannst du hellen Flecken kommen oder
wenn man vor allem in die Sonne geht
kannst z dunklen Flecken kommen die
ganze Zeit la aber ich musste ich muss
mir so das Lachen verkneif in der
Situation ne ich sit da hinter mir zwei
Jungs mit der Kamera rechts der Leiter
vomud vor eine Ärztin V mir mich so eine
laserw ich so ja sin ja ich ich kann nie
ernst bleiben in solchen Situationen
gibt's noch Fragen nö alles
super e ich die dachten auch der Typ ne
gar keine Ahnung hat keine Fragen sagt
der packt das schon ja komm jetzt geht's
auf jeden Fall dann los mit dem Lasern
das ist das Tattoo du guckst dir das
noch mal
kurz e ich find's sorry ich weiß nicht
ob ich das so lustig finde aber ich
finde es immer so stumpf mir Videos von
mir selbst anzuschauen die aber nicht
ich selbst geschnitten habe und hier
hochgeladen habe sondern sowas wie hier
wo ich da sitze auf so einer Liege Hose
runtergezogen wir haben ich war mal bei
Kai flaume der ein Tag mit mir verbracht
vor einem Jahr oder irgendwie so da habe
ich auch noch nie auf das Video reagiert
weil ich das wä die ganze Zeit so ich
wär nur am
lachen ich s einfach ohne
Hose ja so bisschen nbe fühlt man schon
aber jetzt nichts was mich stören würde
ich die desinfizieren das ich pack noch
mal mit meinen Händen gerade vom Fahrrad
gekommen da drauf ja du müsstest eine
Brille aufsetzen e diese Brille sieht so
geil aus guckt euch das mal an wir alle
guck mal
wie absolut Laser
so von Bräune her Ordnung
oder kennt ihr das wenn man
vor einfach nur ich so dachte ja ich
stell noch mal irgende Frage dass der
Lehrer denkt ich habe auch eine Frage
aber du weißt gar nicht meh was du
Fragen sollst die Bräune was mit zu tun
hat ich sit einfach nur so ich frage
jetzt mal was wovon er dann denkt dass
ich bestimmt zugehört habe und Ahnung
davon habe so haben immer noch so
stressbälchen J das war krass da hat er
mir diese Bälle in die Hand gegeben
meinte nur se ja wenn es weh tut einfach
die Bälle drücken ihr seht gleich meine
Schmerzen pass auf ich ma jetzt ein
Punkt das zwiebelt ein bisschen Moment
der muss noch mal hochfahren was ist
wenn ich irgendwie so zucke oder so ist
schim nicht schlimm so
Achtung ach so ja okay
entspann da hat er erstmal nur einen
Punkt gemacht und dann ist mir erstm
aufgefallen ja okay diger das ist ja
überhaupt nicht schlimm der fährt dann
halt das ganze Tattoo ab die einzige
Herausforderung für Behandler ist das
man während der Behandlung dass die
Stelle richtig gekühlt wird ne also wir
haben ein ein einer Hand das
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Kühlgerät dieses wel beschreibt das
komplette Video er erklärt irgendwas und
ich gar nicht zu den uh er hat schon ein
bisschen es ist wirklich wie so ganz
ganz ganz ganz kleine Mikronadeln die
man in die Haut gerammt bekommt mit
einer extremen Geschwindigkeit ja also
no joke genauso habe ich halt auch
gefühlt das war einfach wie so kennt ihr
diese Stifte die so vier Stifte
gleichzeitig da drin ich habe sogar ein
hier die hatte man früher mal in der
Schule da konnte man dann so
verschiedene Farben auswählen konnte
dann sagen so zack ich will jetzt die
Farbe oder zack ich will jetzt die Farbe
wenn alle diese vier Dinger die da drin
sind auf einmal so mit Sonner
Geschwindigkeit also mit tausendfacher
keine Ahnung was Geschwindigkeit so in
deiner Haut und so ganz klein so fühlt
sich an dann auch noch eine
Betäubungssalbe die müssen die Leute
aber selbst drauf machen weil die muss
Stunde einwirken ne ja das habe ich halt
nicht gemacht weil ich bin im
Nehmen ja Respekt guck mal du konnst
noch mit mir reden ne das war's das war
ja das habe ich gar nicht verstanden ich
dachte der geht jetzt irgendwie fünf Mal
darüber der ist nur einmal kurz darüber
gegangen das war wirklich eine Sache von
anderthalb Minuten diesen drei Zeiler da
bei mir da irgendwie zu Laser kann
abnehmen die BR jetzt kannst du abnehmen
du hast die Farbe
zertrümmert und es sieht jetzt so schön
hell aus aber das
ist ich einfach fünf und dann kommen wir
an die tieferliegende Schicht und so
weiter aber ist ja echt interessant dass
der Laser dann sagt okay ich erkenne wo
ein Tattoo ist oder wo gestochen wird
und nur das wird angegangen
quasi oh wow ey ich bin so ein Vollidiot
also ja ich habe es richtig gesagt aber
ich wiederhole dann einfach nur das was
er gesagt hat um halt das ist genauso
wie im Unterricht wenn sich so zwei
Leute melden dann meldet sich der erste
und deine Antwort war eigentlich falsch
gewesen du checkst dann dass seine
Antwort richtig war und dann wirst du
auch noch dran sagst ja ich wollte es
das gleiche auch noch mal sagen und der
Spot bei dem Gerät wird in zehn Mal pro
Sekunde gesetzt ja das heißt du hast
relativ schnell auch größere Tattoos
abgefahren ja ist ja echt
abgefahren oh mein Gott da konnte mich
gar mehr dran erinnern dass ich den Joke
gebracht ich weiß den hat im ganzen Raum
da standen vier Leute noch ne hat
niemand den Joke gecheckt ich so ist
echt abgefahren wie schnell man so
Tattoo abgefahren hat und er er hat auch
nicht verstanden ja wie war's für dich
äh angenehm wä gelogen auf jeden Fall
also es hat schon leicht gezwirbelt aber
jetzt nicht mehr als ich irgendwie
gedacht hatte also es ist vergleichbar
mit den Schmerzen die man hat wenn man
das Tattoo gestochen bekommt ja es war
so ein bisschen bisschen doller war es
schon also ich will meine ehrliche
Meinung hier sagen wir quatschen da
jetzt nur noch mal kurz fassen das so
ein bisschen zusammen ich habe euch das
komplette Video natürlich auch unten in
der Beschreibung verlinkt von mir auch
noch mal an euch hier ganz transparent
das was ich auch schon zu Beginn gesagt
habe ich werde für dieses Video nicht
bezahlt ich muss dieses Video hier nicht
machen er hatte mich gefragt ob es okay
ist dass er das so ein bisschen
kameratechnisch begleitet habe ich halt
gesagt ja okay von mir aus völlig in
Ordnung weil das ja dann auch für mich
nur heißt ey die wollen das präsentieren
das heißt die geben sich wahrscheinlich
echt sehr viel Mühe dabei
für mich war es eine super coole
Erfahrung
ich kann aber erst sagen ob der Laden
jetzt gut ist oder nicht wenn das Tattoo
halt weg ist also in ein Jahr mache ich
dann vielleicht noch mal so ein Video
aber mich haben halt extrem viele von
euch bei Instagram angeschrieben meinten
nur so ey ich habe auch ein Tattoo oder
meine Tochter oder mein mein Sohn und
bla und dann dies und das und bla kannst
du es empfehlen die dasar auch Freunde
von mir ey wie war's Blabla erzähl mal
deswegen ähm ja bitte für die Info wir
sehen uns morgen im neuen Video wieder
ciao